Rob here with a gamespot news update
according to the director of star wars
the force awakens the episode 8 script
is completed episode 8 is being written
and directed by loopers ryan johnson in
a lengthy interview with wired Abrams
said the script 48 is written I'm sure
rewrites are going to be endless like
they always are but what Larry and I did
was set up certain key relationships
certain key questions and conflicts and
we know where certain things were going
I show Ryan early cut of a movie because
I knew he was doing his rewrite and
prepping and as executive producer of
eight I need that movie to be really
good with holding serves no one and
certainly not the fans so we've been as
transparent as possible Abrams also
spoke about the need to make the force
awakens work as a standalone movie for
new viewers to the Star Wars universe
not just for longtime fans we wanted to
tell a story that had its own
self-contained beginning middle and end
but at the same time like a new hope
implied a history that preceded it and
also hinted at a future to follow the
past few days we've seen two new
trailers for the film released both
containing previously unseen footage a
full trailer for Japanese audiences and
a new TV spot star wars the force
awakens opens December 18 2015 and in
honor of the new TV spot
star wars the force awakens